GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So today is unforced--
that means zero
on the right-hand side, looking
for null solutions-- damped--
that means there
is a coefficient B
in the first derivative.
And what's the solution?
This is really a
basic, basic equation.
In many applications,
A would be the mass.
In a spring, for example,
A would be a mass.
B is the damping, the friction.
And C is the spring
constant, the force
that pulls the mass back.
Or in electronics, B
would be the resistance.
It's giving some friction,
giving some heat.
So that's our equation.
Just we have to be
able to solve it.
And we want to look
for exponentials.
A pure exponential is just
right for a constant coefficient
equation like that.
So I'll substitute y equals e
to the st. And what happens?
Well, so there's a C e
to the st. That's a Cy.
The derivative brings down an s.
Two derivatives
bring down s squared.
So I simply have As
squared, Bs, and C
all together, multiplying e
to the st. And how'd I get 0?
Well the 0 is not going
to come from e to the st,
so it has to come from this.
So fundamentally, the
whole video and more
is about a quadratic equation.
As squared plus Bs
plus C equals 0.
We have to solve it.
We have to understand how
does the answer depend
on these numbers, A and
B and C, the constants?
OK?
So we know the route.
We know the solutions.
The quadratic formula tells us
that the two solutions-- there
are always two,
but they could be
equal-- have this-- do you
recognize this expression?
You see the damping
coefficient coming in.
You see this all
important square root,
which tells us, depending
on whether B squared is
bigger than 4AC, B
squared is equal 4AC,
B squared is smaller.
So smaller B means less damping.
And it would be
called underdamping..
So here are the possibilities.
B could be 0.
That puts us back
in a previous video
when the solution was a pure
complex exponential, pure sine
cosine.
There was no damping.
It just oscillated forever.
That's the one we know.
Now, the new ones with a B are
B squared could be smaller.
So that's only a little damping.
And in that case, what does
the solution look like?
If B squared is
smaller than 4AC,
I have to always look back here.
So I have something negative.
Something negative,
a minus B over 2A.
And then plus or
minus-- and what's
important point about this guy?
B squared is smarter than 4AC.
This is negative inside.
So its square root is
an imaginary number.
So the plus or minus,
there's an imaginary number.
A little different from
the natural frequency.
It's called the damp frequency.
Not quite as frequent.
The damping slows the
oscillation down a little bit,
but it brings in
exponential decay.
I'll draw a picture this time
or next time of the solution,
e to the minus st.
But you see, e to the
minus st is decaying to 0.
It's like a spring that's
slowly winding down to 0.
But it's oscillating
as it does it.
OK.
Now, we've got two more
possibilities here.
And these are just
fun to get straight.
There's the next one.
When B squared is exactly 4AC.
Exactly 4AC.
B squared over 4AC, that's going
to be the critical ratio here.
And here that ratio is 1.
And in that case, that
square root is nothing.
The square root of B
squared minus 4AC is 0.
So we get s1 and s2 equal.
Two equal frequencies.
Real numbers.
They're the minus B over 2A.
So s1 and s2 are
both minus B over 2A.
That's just the edge between
the decay with oscillation
from underdamping.
And the opposite
extreme is overdamping.
Overdamping, when B
squared is bigger than 4AC,
then our formula-- we're
always looking back
at that quadratic formula.
B squared bigger than
4AC, this is real.
Square root of a
positive number.
It's perfectly real.
So in that case, we
have two, s1 and s2.
Oh, let me draw
you some pictures.
I'll draw you the
parabola, the As squared.
So this is a graph
of As squared.
Let me plot As squared
plus Bs plus C.
So in this overdamping case,
we might have a lot of damping.
B is pretty large.
And that would be--
this direction is s.
And I'm graphing here s squared
plus-- well, let me see.
I think probably plus 2s.
And now I'm going to
choose this-- oh, actually,
plus 0 to get that one.
So this has a root at--
this is overdamping.
Overdamping.
A big number there.
C is 0.
No mass at all.
No stiffness at all.
So this parabola has a root
at 0 and a root at minus 2.
That would be an extreme case
with no stiffness whatever.
Now, let me add some stiffness.
So what happens if I
change the constant term?
It lifts the graph.
So let me make it 1.
So I move the whole
graph up by 1.
So you see that as I
move it up, these roots
will come closer and closer.
And at the right point,
when I move it up to 1,
what's going on there?
Critical damping.
This is the case s
squared plus 2s plus 1.
Which is exactly s plus 1 twice.
And it has that repeated
root, which we always
recognized as the marginal
case when it doesn't go below,
but it doesn't
stay above either.
It hits here twice.
So the root is minus 1 twice.
That's critical.
And now what?
Increase this constant
C even further.
You'll lift the graph,
lift the parabola up here.
Lift it by one more, let's say.
And what's going on there?
So this would be s
squared plus 2s plus 2.
And you see what that
graph is telling us.
It's telling us there are
no roots, no real roots.
This is a real graph in the
real plane, and it's never 0.
This is s plus 1.
This is the case when I have
s plus 1 squared plus 1.
Can't be 0.
Never 0.
So this has-- sorry.
With the 2 there,
it has damping.
It has damping, but
it's underdamping.
The roots are complex.
So this s plus 1 squared is 0.
What are the roots of that?
s is minus 1 plus or minus i.
That's the case of underdamping.
So let me write that.
We see so much
from these graphs.
So this was a graph
in which I changed
the constant term, the
capital C, the stiffness, k.
So that lifted the graph.
And eventually the
roots were complex.
They weren't real anymore,
because the parabola
didn't cross the axis anymore.
The roots are where
it crosses the axis.
So that's one.
I'll draw in the next
video another picture.
Maybe change B.
Change the damping.
So what would happen if
I change the damping?
If there's no damping, the
roots are pure imaginary.
Yeah.
Let's just go back through
those four possibilities,
because that's what
you have to learn.
If B is 0, there's
no damping at all.
And we're back in
the pure oscillation,
where is pure imaginary.
We're just seeing
cosines and sines.
Then if we add a little damping,
there appears a decay turn.
If we add-- I could even
draw these possibilities.
Let me draw the solution
y of t, against t.
OK.
So underdamping--
the solutions say
it starts there-- will
oscillate, but decay.
So this is underdamping.
And you remember
when that happens?
That's when B is
present but smaller.
B squared is smaller than 4AC.
Overdamping, if it
starts, let's say,
here, it will going
to 0, probably
with no oscillation at all.
It could have one oscillation.
Depends how it starts.
So ooh, let me
make this picture.
So that one is the overdamping.
This guy is the underdamping.
Underdamping still
has oscillations.
Overdamping has, at most, once.
It could cross once.
But overdamping is B
squared bigger than 4AC.
OK.
There's more to do.
This is so central that you have
to think about the ratio of B
squared to 4AC.
That has its own name.
And it's a damping ratio, or
the square of a damping ratio.
And we identify all
these solutions.
Does everybody know where the
solution will be when B is 0?
No damping at all.
In that case, it
will just oscillate.
So my picture is getting, you
could say, a little messed up.
But this pure
oscillation would be
the B equals 0 with undamped.
OK.
That's a first look at
quadratic equations.
As squared plus Bs plus C. It
has the big name characteristic
equation, but you
could see, it's
the fundamental equation for
a second order differential
equation.
So we'll see more of it.
Thanks.